en un mensaje a medios en el que no se
permitieron preguntas de la prensa El
general secretario de la defensa
nacional crescencio Sandoval confirmó la
captura de Ovidio Guzmán hijo de Joaquín
El Chapo Guzmán en un operativo de
fuerzas federales en el Estado de
Sinaloa detalló que esto fue posible
gracias a un trabajo de seis meses de
inteligencia y seguimiento y precisó que
fueron elementos de la guardia nacional
esta corporación de seguridad creada en
el actual sexenio quienes dieron con el
paradero e identificaron el lugar donde
se resguardaba Ovidio Guzmán cuyo
sicarios trataron sin éxito de impedir
la captura el general Sandoval Consideró
que este es un golpe contundente al
cártel de Sinaloa Ovidio Guzmán de hecho
ya fue trasladado vía aérea a la ciudad
de México para ser puesto a disposición
de la fiscalía especial en materia de
delincuencia organizada esta captura ha
generado una ola de violencia en Sinaloa
pues se reportan bloqueos por parte del
crimen organizado incluso la aerolínea
aero reportó que uno de sus aviones que
estaba a punto de despegar en el
aeropuerto de Culiacán recibió un
impacto de bala en el fuselaje lo que
provocó el pánico de los pasajeros y la
tripulación este y todos los demás
vuelos han sido cancelados el llamado a
la población por parte de las
autoridades sigue siendo a que
permanezcan en casa y se mantengan
informados el canciller mexicano Marcelo
ebrard negó que esta aprensión haya
obedecido a la exigencia de Estados
Unidos país que requiere en extradición
a Ovidio Guzmán pues lo considera el
dirigente de esta organización criminal
el cartel de Sinaloa y también tiene
distintos cargos contra el relacionados
con el narcotráfico